prost wenn es was zu feiern gibt ist der
sekt nicht weit
sebastian panscht frucht sowie die
industrie und nelson lässt günstige
champagner vom discounter gegen das
luxus original antreten
[Musik]
prosecco ist eine beliebte spezialität
aus italien viel günstiger aber genau so
wohlklingend secolo sato brisante oder
frucht 6
schnäppchen oder mogelpackung nelson und
seine gäste suchen die unterschiede
kauft ihr sowas
es ist ein chardonnay das kennt man
irgendwie würde ich sagen aha dann ist
das gut sein ja ganz viele prosecco ist
nur wein prosecco aus bin jetzt hin oder
friaul venetien aber das genaue
anbaugebiet ist da nicht ganz genau so
also muss mich ganz genau festgelegt
sein
ja genau das muss auch musiker ist eine
geschützte herkunftsbezeichnung
er darf nur in venetien oder friaul
abgefüllt und verarbeitet werden
außerdem sind nur trauben der sorte
lehrer zugelassen nennt man das getränk
dagegen frizzante oder frucht 6 dann
bleibt der schöne klang und die strengen
vorschriften lassen sich umgehen
aromatisierten weinhaltigen getränke der
fruchtig prickelnde genuss für gesellige
stunden
das passt ja
[Musik]
er schmeckt wie hello kitty sechs kinder
da ist unser ausgesucht
der schmeckt mir sogar
[Musik]
aber was steckt darin produktentwickler
sebastian nägel kennt die tricks der
lebensmittelindustrie und will uns
zeigen was alles möglich ist
dazu wird er heute einen feinfühligen
säcke rosato kreieren klingt italienisch
luxuriös trauben aus italien braucht er
deswegen aber noch lange nicht daraus
mache ich gleich mal im schaumwein
lecker mit ein bisschen farbe
aromatisiert da kann die schwiegermutter
in ihrem feiertagen auch mal ein
bisschen mehr trägen billiger wein als
basis natürlich nicht aus italien
traubensaft und traubenzucker für den
geschmack und noch eine ganz besondere
zutat grillkohle wenn man coaching rot
oder mit der ergiebigsten
lebensmittelfarben die es gibt ist ein
produkt einer blattlaus hört sich echt
ein bisschen gruselig an aber stimmt der
farbstoff coccinelle rot kommt schon
seit 3000 jahren zum einsatz weil er
licht und wärme beständig ist wird er
auch in lippenstiften und bei
süßigkeiten verwendet der guten ihrem
tritt
[Musik]
jetzt heißt es simsalabim aus normalen
tetra pak war schöne rose in einem
echten rosé sekt entsteht die farbe
durch pigmente die in der schale der
trauben enthalten sind
doch diese fermentierung braucht zeit
zeit die man sich mit dem farblichen
einfach sparen kann
dazu gib lege traubensaft für das aroma
bisschen was für die süße noch da fehlen
jetzt nur noch die bläschen aber das ist
eher die leichtigkeit einfachen
südamerika
so
[Musik]
auch in der industrie spart man sich die
langwierige flaschengärung stattdessen
wird einfach wein mit kohlensäure
versetzt
statt prosecco entsteht so ein ähnlich
blubbernde sendak produkt ist rot
super gewesen sind drin aber an den ganz
schöne sauerei ich gerade faden streitet
abgefüllt in eine schöne flasche schon
macht es was her
würd mal sagen da kommt keiner drauf
dass das bein aus dem tetrapack
und jetzt sagen wir mal viel richtig
gute stimmung hier am set
wer möchte in gläschen nach da war
bitteschön
sowohl
so kenne ja schon sehr ladylike getränk
aber lecker im supermarktregal findet
man solche produkte als perle kubino
brisante oder sakko rosato der fantasie
sind keine grenzen gesetzt
auch echte luxus artikel wie champagner
führende discounter mittlerweile für
gerade mal 13 euro luxus zum
schnäppchenpreis wie sich der billig
champagner schlägt möchten wir von
christine banier wissen sie ist
französische sommelier und kennt sich
mit champagner bestens aus es ist
verwunderlich ist es champagner vom
discounter auch einen teuren marken
champagner geben wir in den blind wird
er herausstechen
ich würde mal interessieren was eine
expertin eine gestandene somalier hre
dazu sagt du musst du dich erst mal
probieren um darüber zu sprechen
in der flasche ist ganz ganz viel druck
immer viel mehr druck als in einem
autoreifen liebe ist ja das ist das
mineralwasser in der küche zwei profis
beim test werden sie den teuren
champagner herausschmecken
[Musik]
ich würde sagen lasst uns mal ist mal
richten war denke ich wir können schon
mal zwischendurch mal probieren oder
dann wenn du ein spannendes probiert
hast dann hast du den geschmack kommen
wir haben auch eine frucht note
auch nicht etwas lustiges zu fast ein
bisschen so ganz ganz eingeliefert und
an einen spruch anbietern alles gut ich
denke jetzt hat unsere nase so viel
aromen zu sich genommen da müssen wir
noch mal von vorne an staaten und
probieren aber ich würde auch gegangen
die discounter champagner kosten nur
einen bruchteil des markenprodukts kann
einer mithalten
also das heißt wer wochen haben setzt
sich auch vorsätzlich schon vor der
gefällt mir sehr gut
sehr gute noten für penny und lidl
da muss ich sagen da muss ich keinen
champagner trinken nein das würde ich
nicht als champagner anstoßen vielleicht
hast du eine andere produkt mit
eingeschleust aber kaum schmeckt was
nicht so gut
lidl fällt durch und wie schlägt sich
das counter riese an die würzige ganz
deutlich das ganze fällen sind sehr
angenehm gute wertungen für aldi fehlt
netto
ich schmecke schmecken das ist ein
schauer einer welle riss die so ein
regeln die die unteren davor
und jetzt der marken champagner für 40
euro
immerhin der beliebteste champagner der
welt
aber der war ja sehr intensiv um das ist
nicht mein geschmack auch nicht trocken
so etwas billiges benzin ist was mir als
sehr unangenehm erscheint also das
gefällt mir nicht mehr auch nicht mehr
[Musik]
ausgerechnet das teure marken produkt
fällt durch aber welcher champagner wird
sieger der stichprobe seine absolute
nummer eins unter diesen also man über
alles ist nur 123 die um vor allem penny
schneiden besonders gut ab und darf bei
gerade mal 13 euro pro flasche
das ist hätte nur fünf dass die nummer
fünf den den wir als am fehlerhaftesten
empfunden haben
die große überraschung ausgerechnet
dieser champagner ist kein champagner
vom discounter sondern eine ganz
bekannte und berühmte marke wenige
winzer aber viel überraschender der
verlierer murex denn mit dieser
platzierung hätte keiner gerechnet
[Musik]
fruchtiger sec oder teurer champagner
mit was schluss die an silvester an sagt
es uns in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer essen
wissen wollt denn abonniert zdf besser
esser und schaut in die nächsten zwei
clips